what's going on guys this is rob and i
feel like i should hire a co-host for
the rumor roundup but in this video
we're gonna be
ranking the top five marvel cinematic
universe
shows so far now to keep things simple
we're going to be using shows
that tie closely into the mcu or
directly into the mcu
i.e a combination of what we've seen so
far on disney plus
and netflix although maybe one day we'll
include shows like x-men the animated
series
although admittedly that would be number
one so coming in at number five we've
got
falcon and the winter soldier and by no
means is this show
bad in reality it's the closest to a
movie that we've had in the marvel
cinematic universe tv show so far
it's pretty straightforward there's not
a lot of guessing going on here there
really wasn't much in the realm of
suspicion
or possible mystery or anything like
that and in reality i think that's one
of the things that held the show back
i think coming out of wanda vision and
the fact that we were all speculating
that really mephisto was the one that
was behind it all that it led people
down this path of wanting
shows that had a lot of mystery and
intrigue a lot of curiosity
that kind of allowed our imaginations to
run wild falcon of the winter soldier
didn't really give us that but what it
lacked in that department
it more than made up for in storytelling
and action
the action sequences in that show were
amazing i loved them especially baron
zemo i loved seeing him fight and get
into conflicts and things like that
i loved the action scenes and really
kind of the buddy cobb aspect between
falcon and the winter soldier
so i'd definitely love to see the show
come back i just think the lack of
mystery and intrigue the lack of the
ability of my imagination to run wild
really kind of moves the show down
further on the list than it possibly
could have been
number four on our list here is jessica
jones
and there's only one reason why this
show even made the list in the first
place because i'll be honest with you
guys
the only real thing that i was looking
forward to outside of the purple man
was when luke cage figured out jessica
jones had powers
and what they would do how that scene
would unfold when the two of them
realized what they were capable of
outside of that i didn't really care
about jessica jones i didn't really have
a whole lot of interest in jessica jones
and a lot of that's just because of the
fact that
coming from comic books jessica jones
was never really that interesting
in the first place and even with the
original comic book series by blind
michael bendis as part of the marvel max
line which was marvel's adult-oriented
line of comics
the purple man was the only really cool
part of that
and it applied in the same way to the tv
show i gotta say
purple man stole that show i absolutely
loved zebedai kilgrave and the jessica
jones tv show
because it was just so great the way he
handled things
because he would have these moments
where he would freak out and use his
powers
but there were also like funny little
small moments right a really good
example of this
is the moment when he's talking to
jessica jones in the police station
and he's getting really irritated and
then like somebody's phone rings
and he's like the next person whose
phone rings has to
eat it and it's just like damn like
they're gonna have to actually eat their
phone right because
the purple man makes you do things that
you don't want to do right the
pheromones the stuff he puts off
but then there's a really funny moment i
don't know if it's supposed to be funny
but it was funny to me
a funny moment when jessica jones is
following uh that one guy that was
essentially taken by kilgrave and kind
of put in that position
but she's following him and then there's
a point where she sees kilgrave and like
he's at a news stand
and this guy is like giving him a hard
time he's like hey man like he's kind of
like kilgrave looks down and he's just
like pick up your coffee and like fix
the coffee up and he's like splash it in
your face
like he's like wow i started screaming
and carrying on
i thought that was hilarious i know it's
probably not supposed to be
but i thought it was funny as hell i
laughed i laughed at that scene
but kilgrave was this character that
even though i was initially resistant to
the idea
of humanizing him i just wanted to see
just like the downright
evil sociopathic vindictive kilgray from
the comics
i loved what they did that he was kind
of a tragic character right it was a
little tragic in that way
one of the most disappointing things is
the marvel cinematic universe did what
they always do
which was kill him off and i would love
to have seen him return because one of
the things that a lot of people don't
know
about kilgrave is that unless you're
dealing with somebody that has a great
healing factor like wolverine
or possibly the incredible hulk kilgrave
can take over them right like
during michael bendis new avengers run
he seized control of luke cage and it
was just by sheer willpower that luke
cage was able to resist it
but purple man is an avengers level
threat right like he's pretty
significant
and so i would love to have seen him be
carried over into the mcu movie line
and actually see him be presented as a
credible threat to the avengers
themselves
now moving on to number three we've got
loki
and loki was a great tv show here's the
thing that i loved about loki so much
right one of the things that i loved
about loki
the idea of the multiverse i for one as
a comic book fan
i'm a bigger fan of stories that involve
like cosmic entities
and super powerful beings and things
like that and there was
a lot of mystery here right it's one
thing that we were all speculating about
who's actually running the tva and
what's going on with timekeepers
a lot of you guys called kang a long
time ago so kudos to you
for getting it right it's one of the
coolest things that i love reading about
you all's theories and the comments that
you guys have and different things like
that but
uh the show itself it was cool and i
would love to see
more of what goes on there the biggest
thing that i had the biggest problem
that i had with the show
is it ended on the biggest cliffhanger
ever
the return of the multiverse dot dot dot
lucky will return to season two that was
the one thing that drove me nuts
everything else about that show was
fantastic and i gotta say
i loved that they focused they finally
gave tom hiddleston some room
to kind of stretch his wings and to see
what he was capable of because i feel
like one of the biggest issues that held
tom hiddleston's loki back in the marvel
cinematic universe movies
is that he was confined to the role of
being the mischievous brother of thor
and that was it he did have some funny
moments but only as it related to thor
you don't really see him doing anything
outside of that
i feel like this show explored the
depths and the character of loki in a
way
that i never even imagined they would
and i
love his character now sylvie was a
great character as well
and i love the direction they took with
her right that even after everything
that happened
she was still adherent to the mission
destroying the head of the tva
she would not be deterred so much so
that as weird as it is and the fact that
her and loki were basically in love with
each other which is strange to me
she turned against him right sent him
flying through that portal and then
killed a mortise and that was basically
it
uh i loved it right i loved that whole
that the entire writing of the show
the direction of the show right mobius
owen wilson
was amazing i love what they did with
nirvana ren slayer i love the fact that
she wasn't the one who was operating
behind the scenes she wasn't pulling the
strings
that she had as little knowledge of what
was going on as anybody else did and she
was just playing her role
because she believed with the the belief
of a zealot
that the tva's job was effective and it
was and i feel like that was the
greatest takeaway from the entirety of
the show
that sylvie killing a mortis really did
screw everything up right she ruined
everything i brought it all crashing
down and i guess sure it brings about
free will
but with free will also comes the
potential destruction of the multiverse
again
with another multiverse award but the
possibilities that came out of the show
are fantastic because
i love alternate realities and we'll
probably end up seeing with the return
of this multiverse
the various sony movies right so like
the tobey mcguire spider-man films and
the tom hardy venom movies all that kind
of stuff those are just gonna be
alternate realities now right this sets
the stage
for bringing in the fantastic four and
the x-men and so on and so forth
it simplifies a lot of things and and
i'm i'm excited to see what all goes
down
more so than that i very much believe
that the what if series
they're all going to be linked together
there's going to be a kind of common
storyline that runs through every single
episode
even if it's only in a post-credits
scene and it's all going to come
together at the end
and maybe have something to do with
wanda or doctor strange or something
like that i honestly really have no idea
but i am excited to see how this ties in
because i really
don't believe the what if series is
going to be in isolation
i don't think it's really going to be or
really be separated from anything else
in the mcu
i think it's going to have like what's
going to come out of that show is going
to have a kind of common plot thread
that has huge effects across the rest of
the mcu
so coming in at number two on our list
one division and this show was great one
division was really like the first foray
into a tv show for the mcu and i gotta
say they knocked it out of the park
one of the things that i will say i do
understand why a lot of people dropped
off
in the first two episodes i totally
understand that they were very slow
and i certainly get where people are
coming from where they're just like i
mean this is
boring right this is really dumb and it
was designed to be reminiscent of like
old school
tv right like back in the days of dick
van dyke and all that kind of stuff but
i felt like it was a little too slow
not enough happen in the first or second
episodes and one of the things that
anybody who will tell you
especially if they're like a youtube
content creator will tell you like the
first five seconds of a youtube video
will decide whether people stay or go
and tv shows are the exact same way you
get one episode you only get one first
episode
and then if that first episode doesn't
latch people in they're gone and off to
the next thing
and that's something that the mcu kind
of needed to to kind of keep in mind
with the one division show having said
that what the first episode locked in
interest
the rest of the episodes made up for
for you poor saps who dropped off in the
first episode and didn't finish it
i feel sorry for you because you missed
out
because now you're playing catch-up and
i feel like wanda vision because of all
the excitement and all the theory
crafting and things like that
it's one of those things you kind of had
to be there there was no feeling
and i'm sure you guys feel the same way
there was no feeling like being part of
like this kind of
youtube geek culture comic book tv show
community
across all facets of social media as the
episodes were coming out because if you
guys were anything like me you were just
coming up with all these different
theories
you know for the most part i never
really looked at a lot of theories
online largely because of the fact that
the theories that i that i came up with
i wanted to kind of come up with
organically
now i do recognize i wasn't the first
person to come up with those theories
but i did like the idea of just trying
to think about what sort of things would
happen
and i loved being part of that community
where it's like mephisto is behind it
all you know
i really wanted mephisto to be involved
in some form or fashion in hindsight i
do get it
that disney the wholesome family
property would not want to attach their
name
to satan i understand that
i'd grasp that but i still think it
would have been cool
if we'd seen mephisto in the marvel
cinematic universe i think at this point
the mephisto theory has essentially
taken on a life of its own right like
if there is a chance for people to
speculate that mephisto is going to
appear in the mcu
they're going to speculate man i know i
will in the loki tv show we literally
saw that glass painting
where it was like the devil it's like oh
my god is that a mephisto reference like
you guys remember that
everybody was like is that a mephisto
reference like oh my god mephisto is in
loki right he's running the tv hey you
know
mephisto got tired of hell and decided
to create an organization that monitors
the entirety of the multiversal time
stream
uh it seems a little ridiculous in
hindsight but who cares it was awesome
it was fun to talk about so
one division definitely comes in at
number two on my list
which really begs the question what show
comes in at number one
well to answer that question that show
is
daredevil season one and i imagine some
people probably gonna look at that and
say really daredevil
you'd put daredevil season one in number
one absolutely and here's the reason why
kingpin matt murdock was okay right like
matt murdock was a pretty simple
character he's what you'd expect from a
character in the marvel cinematic
universe or something that ties into the
marvel cinematic universe right
there's not a whole lot to the character
of matt murdock and even in the comics
there hasn't been i will say
the most interesting matt murdock had
been since the days of frank miller
was probably during superior iron man
when tony stark gave him his eyesight
back
to show him the power of extremists and
basically get matt murdock off his back
right tony stark during superior iron
man
was kind of being a dick if you guys
want to know more about that check the
link in the description it'll link you
over to the playlist at comics explained
but uh but nonetheless that was a really
interesting concept with his character
in all reality i think like the the
greatest aspect of the daredevil season
one tv show
was kingpin man kingpin was fantastic
vincent d'onofrio i honestly didn't
really even know how good of a kingpin
he would be
because vince dofrios played so many
types of roles he's a very eclectic
actor
but the speech he gave at the end you
guys remember that like the speech he
gave at the very end when he was talking
about like the
the man who was walking on the road and
so on and so forth and he's like
i am the ill intent like that was just a
ridiculously good speech
but the development of kingpin's
character over the course of the show
was fantastic but i do love the dynamic
between like foggy nelson and matt
murdock and karen page and that kind of
a thing
but those guys weren't all that wildly
intriguing
whenever i go back and i watch the show
i find myself skipping over a lot of
those scenes with daredevil and foggy
nelson and karen page
i watch some of them and i end up
finding myself focusing mostly on the
scenes with kingpin
i just kind of gravitate in that
direction the development of his
character was fantastic
and one of the things that i'm really
really hoping for is that the idea of
him being in the marvel cinematic
universe movies
are actually going to happen because
there's a lot of rumors that that's the
case i don't know if anything's actually
been confirmed
but there's a lot of rumors that are
saying that vincent afrio's kingpin
is actually going to be in the mcu and
he's going to become a future villain of
spider-man
i thought it was all just beautifully
crafted right every episode just felt
like this kind of work of art as a
series progressed
and it was it was phenomenal so for that
reason daredevil comes in
at number one on my list but if you guys
have any shows
you felt like should have made this list
let us know down in the comment section
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace